this is tomoh hussein reading for
reviewer heidi kemps everybody has their
bad days one moment you're walking home
from school and the next thing you know
the class jackass has dragged you and
your friends into a biblical apocalypse
while trying to create the next viral
hit video and then you wind up sharing
your body with a supernatural warrior
trying to survive amongst the demonic
forces roaming and ruining tokyo long
enough to figure out what the hell is
going on at least that's how things go
in the world of shin megami tensei v the
latest numbered incarnation atlas's
long-running rpg series where once again
tokyo has found itself at the epicenter
of a global demon apocalypse naturally
you're the person who can change the
fate of the humans and demons alike will
you fight with the forces of heaven to
spread holy law across the land embrace
the might and freedom of the forces of
chaos or walk a neutral path no matter
what choice you make your journey won't
be an easy one but it will be very
rewarding
you begin shin megami tensei five as a
simple student but it's not long before
you're standing amongst a ruined tokyo
watching angels spiriting away your
buddies and being beset upon by
supernatural beings a strange demon
offers you his power for protection and
you fuse with him becoming najobino a
demon human hybrid with the potential to
wield god-like powers the key word being
potential since your life is now hell on
earth quite literally almost every
single god or demon from humanity's
collective belief system is now running
a mark in what was once a bustling
metropolis as a result you need to
carefully pick your allies and call them
to your aid as well as manage your own
abilities in order to survive in vicious
turn-based combat to become the almighty
being you are meant to be
[Music]
a hallmark of the mainline smt series
and a system that has made its way to
the persona offshoot is the character
being able to control demons in battle
and in order to do this you need to be
able to win them over to your side you
have a command to talk in every fight
which begins an interaction with one of
the demons you're facing you'll need to
figure out what the demon wants from you
choose the right dialogue options to
pique their interest and then negotiate
their demands for items money and
sometimes even your life and ability
energy
[Music]
if you succeed they'll join your gang
but if things turn sour you might be in
for a nasty surprise
[Music]
but negotiation isn't always an option
so you'll need to be prepared for some
fierce fights smt-5s combat is a tug of
war to attain an advantage you're
rewarded with extra turns for securing
critical strikes and hitting enemy
weaknesses with extra actions in combat
but if your attacks are blocked or
dodged your turns will evaporate before
your eyes every turn you can gain is
precious because once the enemy gets an
opportunity to strike they go all in
looking to exploit your team's weak
points and gleefully dismantle your
strategy the flow of combat is easy to
grasp but fully utilizing its nuances to
secure the upper hand and snatch victory
from difficult circumstances is where
the fun lies you do have an ace up your
sleeve in the form of the new magatsuhi
gorge which fills up over battles and
once full can be used by any member of
the party to generate various effects
for a round of battle for example giving
everyone guaranteed critical hits
guaranteeing your strikes and status
elements land sending your elemental
power skyrocketing or even just firing
off an extremely powerful attack that
doesn't cost a turn but enemies can use
magatsuhi powers too and when they do it
can prove absolutely devastating every
single battle you enter including ones
against the generic enemy mobs roaming
the field has the potential to become a
struggle for survival with just one bad
decision it can be an emotional roller
coaster too the elation of watching your
team rack up successful weakness
exploiting attack after attack on a
tough foe turning to crushing dread when
they suddenly dodge and end your combat
phase prematurely for a huge
counter-attack
the best way to prepare for combat lies
in another series staple the ability to
fuse two members of your demon army into
a new more powerful being that can
inherit the skills of its progenitors
demons fused in this fashion can learn
skills otherwise unavailable to them
naturally and are considerably more
powerful than those recruited from the
field using demon fusion wisely is
crucial to making combat resilient party
members with diverse skill sets smt-5
improves the fusion element over
previous titles by not only introducing
a reverse fusion option which allows you
to see the resulting daemon and all the
potential combinations from your current
stock that could create it but also
letting you quickly summon old demons
recorded in your demonic compendium for
reverse fusion but sometimes even fusion
doesn't go quite as planned leaving you
with a fusion accident and results that
you might not expect for better or for
worse the constant possibility that
everything could go pear-shaped in the
blink of an eye creates a tense
atmosphere throughout smt-5 when the
difference between life and death could
lie in whether or not an enemy gets the
first strike exploration is a risk when
basic supplies and demon fusion costs
significant amounts of money but you
also need money for battle negotiations
and healing each purchase is important
every action in smt5 has a weight to it
and that's what makes the game so fun
and engaging but sometimes luck is just
not on your side and then the whole bino
gets blown off the face of the planet
with a couple of consecutive enemy
attacks or debilitated with status
ailments and unable to do anything
useful as your foes tear you apart and
with no auto save and limited save
points you can lose precious progress in
an instant if you get too reckless there
are a few concessions to the player that
make the experience a bit less
oppressive though after a few hours
you'll be given an item that lets you
warp to the last save and recovery point
with the press of a button a life saver
in many situations you can also make use
of essences which are one time use items
containing skills and affinities of
demons that can be applied to the
nahobino or your demonic army to teach
them specific skills without having to
perform lots of fusions essences can
also be used to change the nahobino's
elemental resistances and weaknesses
which is crucial when fighting bosses
finally there are miracles which are
permanent enhancements that grant buffs
like increased elemental damage boosts
to the magatsuhi gorge fusion bonuses
and increased stocks of skills and demon
companions in exchange for glory points
glory is a very limited resource however
so you must choose your enhancements
carefully using these resources well
assigning skills when needed to exploit
current enemy weaknesses combining
upgrades retreating to heal and regroup
strategically can go a very long way in
helping you triumph even with these
additions however you'll find yourself
up against colossal challenges in smt5s
brutal boss battles these battles will
put your skills of demon neutering and
weakness exploitation to a harsh test
and you'll probably get wiped the first
and second and third time you face a
boss you'll need the patience and
persistence to formulate a rock-solid
strategy to get past these battles which
can act as real walls to progress it can
be frustrating and i suspect some
players will give up on smt-5 at certain
points but when you do best these
incredible opponents the sense of
accomplishment is immensely satisfying
patience goes a long way in smt5 in
general because the game is a very slow
burn the eerie art direction and
foreboding atmosphere immediately draw
you in and the story which involves a
war between the forces of god and
lucifer a top secret organization
bizarre experiments and a tremendous
amount of eastern and western religious
symbolism is very intriguing which makes
it a bit of a drag when it doesn't go
anywhere for long stretches the
introductory story beats move along
pretty quickly but once you're merged up
and exploring the desert ruins of
tokyo's minato ward it's going to be 10
to 15 hours before you get to the next
major plot turning point there are quite
a few instances where critical plot
points and character development happens
rapidly followed by long stretches of
exploration and combat before the next
big story event it can be irksome
especially because these sections are so
large and similar looking the combat and
overall atmosphere of smt5 do a lot of
the heavy lifting in these portions but
they only go so far and after a few
hours in a particularly large storylight
netherworld region you really wish for a
change of scenery shin megami tensei 5
is a game that demands a lot of the
player its slow pace and punishing
difficulty will more than likely turn
some folks off but those who stick with
it will find an incredibly rewarding
experience that only gets better the
further you get in smt5 truly makes you
feel like the weight of this crumbling
conflict-torn world of mythological
nightmares rests firmly on your
shoulders but it's a burden you'll be
glad you chose to bear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]